foreign
ER of the internal conspiracy group for
Homeland Security investigations and
this is the man of the hour the case
agent Paul all right I'll just give a
general overview of the case that we
know what's going on
a flight arrived from Curacao to New
York's JFK Airport
on the surveillance video we have the
baggage handler
he's seen offloading the bags this is a
standard procedure this happens
thousands of times a day here at JFK
he's about to pull off with the two
containers after allegedly offloading
the flight
you can see right here those are four
suitcases
three in the first card and one in the
second card
each of those suitcases contains 16
kilograms of cocaine
those four suitcases they are not going
down to customs
the baggage handler decides to drive
around the terminal area
we believe he was doing that as counter
surveillance to see if anyone was
following him
when he stops the baggage cart he goes
into the first container that remember
has the three bags he's pulling the bag
tags off of the pieces of luggage
proceeds to the rear cart where he
removes the tag removes the bag and
places that bag into the first cart
he then unhooks the second car and he
proceeds to drive in the direction of
the domestic baggage terminal drop area
this area is where suitcases go down to
the domestic belt
the whole public has access to that
nobody is there checking tickets with
your name the public can just walk in
take a suitcase off the carousel and
walk right out
after reviewing videotape we were able
to identify a black Honda Accord in the
area of the terminal the same night and
time the suitcases arrived on the
domestic belt we believe that those two
individuals that were inside that black
Honda collected the suitcases and
distributed the cocaine in the New York
area
during the course of our investigation
we ended up arresting the JFK baggage
handler and we did learn that the two
occupants of the black Honda were former
Airline employees here in New York
we then learned that two kilos of
cocaine will be arriving on a flight
tonight from Nassau Bahamas we suspect
that these two same suspects are going
to show up and receive the two kilos of
cocaine
will be to find the drugs coming off the
plane with the assistance of CBP we have
some people on the site already there's
going to be about 26 special agents and
Task Force officers
once the flight lands tonight we're
gonna escort the flight to the gate
we're going to maintain visual contact
at all times with the ramp workers
all the cargo coming off all the
suitcases we want to make sure if
there's any type of narcotic anywhere on
the plane that we get it and then HSI
are going to conduct and control
delivery and try and get the bad guys on
on the outside
we will track the narcotics and let them
go down on the domestic terminal and
then we will see who comes and picks it
up
remember these guys have worked at the
airport before they know the ins and
outs
we're trying to cover every exit every
possible scenario
so just be alert
we have Agents set up outside we're
going to see where the bags go
we'll make a call ultimately when the
drugs get picked up
and we'll decide when we're going to
take this down and affect the arrest
foreign
[Music]
it's not like that anymore they're
getting smart blaster
you hit prove it on the side there's no
sad weight
as we find it they're looking for ways
to hide it better
we're going to be working in Trinidad
now sorry passport
Trinidad is known for Narcotics so would
you like to hit this flight
how you doing passport
are you traveling by yourself yeah okay
what's the purpose of the trip
you have a company over there
what's the name of the store Stylistics
you have any like little uh like
business card or anything
profit how many buddies are you bringing
in I'm breaking about who's this yeah
how do you get your style
when did you buy the ticket to come
so was it planned yeah and when do you
return
Friday
[Music]
if you're a question
what's up
we're gonna go through immigration and
then we're gonna go through a customs
inspection
Hotel it's already paid for
it
all right guys the plans change a little
bit I just got Intel that the cocaine
never made it on the plane
you guys been around long enough you
know we got to be fluid we got to react
the good thing is that we have arrest
warrants for two of our main targets uh
we do know that previously they were in
a black Honda so be on the lookout for
that and since we have all these people
here and we just got these warrants
signed a few hours ago we're going to
execute those arrest warrants today
we've already deployed some people out
to the residence
communicate wait for instructions do not
jump the gun
God
in your car
okay all right we're heading your way
all right thanks
so they got the one guy
the first Target he's in custody now
we're gonna go and pick up the second
target
okay guys this is Kevin and we're set up
on the corner Target's gonna be on the
right probably sitting in the driveway
look to your left this black Honda I
believe it's just right there
that's the black Honda that we saw on
the video from when the cocaine came in
from Curacao
okay Temple and you have the eye on the
set right now yeah
[Music]
because I'm walking to his vehicle okay
so we're right here we might get out and
take him right now
here it is he's right behind you yeah
I'd like to take him somewhere not too
far away like if he gets a block off
he's in his car car hasn't started
he's moving he's moving
what's up
right now we're following behind him
take him up the next light
Chris you pull up to the left we're
going to take the right okay okay
yeah we're gonna take them now we got a
couple cars in place I've got about six
units rolling up on him he might be
turning he's making it right
I advise that we take him mid block yeah
can we get one car ahead of him and take
it yeah
doing that now
okay
foreign
[Music]
very happy so far with the driver just
consented to search of his vehicle so
we'll see if he uh if he has any drugs
or weapons or any evidence of the crime
our agents will go back and they'll
conduct a post arrest interview and
they'll see if he wants to cooperate and
tell us more about what's going on in
the organization
this is the
the third arrest on this case so far
but we still have more people in this
criminal conspiracy we're going after
the high level members of the
organization we're going to take it all
the way up
[Music]
we're going to win this area
and we get the canine here now so
hold on one second step
we have narcotic detector dogs all over
the country you'd be amazed at the
things that dogs can find narcotics
floating in a tank of gasoline that's
sealed
so The Smuggler is to try but we seem to
have a pretty good success rate of
finding it
this is Jax he is trained to detect
narcotics pretty good partner he always
wants to come to work he never complains
about what I want to listen to on the
radio you can stay right there he'll
just sniff around you it's a life of
sacrifice for these dogs they don't get
a lot of Frills but he serves a bigger
purpose than what he understands
canines have been around since the 1970s
back then it was heroin and cocaine and
marijuana
through the years we've had to add
ecstasy and Fentanyl to what our dogs
can find
we have states that are legal marijuana
but federally it's not allowed in so if
you're bringing it in we're still going
to seize it put your bags on the Belt
some yummy food in there the dog might
have liked that okay
nothing else in the bags there's
cigarettes in there
I need marijuana no no marijuana did you
smoke marijuana while you're gone maybe
something like that I'm not sure if I
did not sure if you smoked while you're
right I don't think I did if I did I
wasn't aware do you smoke marijuana in
all you know like you put it in the bag
sometimes of course it's my purse
purse probably why the dog is sitting on
your back is what I'm trying to say many
of that in there before you can't find
it in there now
thank you sir
a lot of times a dog will hit on a
pocket or they'll hit on a purse it's
from where they store it previously so
you're not always going to get someone
that has marijuana does that happen
often my dogs are like oh I mean you
know it's not uncommon
um not a big deal
if that day ever comes where the federal
government recognizes marijuana as a
legal drug then we'll stop training our
dogs on it
right now we're in the middle of
interviewing the two suspects that we
just arrested
we didn't find anything in the black
Honda of note but we did get some
information from the interviews that
there may be another vehicle so we're
going to go out and we have consent to
search that vehicle and we're going to
see what we find
[Music]
this neighborhood that's not entirely
familiar to us yeah we always have to be
aware of our surroundings
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
basically this is a drug dealer starter
kit
really excited about this
we knew we were onto something good we
seized three handguns we seized an
estimated 130 thousand dollars
cash which is a good sign that means
that they were selling the drugs so
these are the importers distributors
investigations are a puzzle you put all
the pieces together
I'm pretty confident that we're going to
get the person that is reaping all the
benefits of this criminal activity
it was just a really good hit
[Music]
all right this is your bag everything
inside is yours
Let Me Get Your Dragon
she's very disorganized so right now
it's just about having a thorough
interview because we want to be able to
catch them in the live
so you said you want to buy about how
much clothes
foreign
and uh after Transportation food
how much money are you bringing in in
cash 500.
and you are 100 sure that credit card
has two thousand dollars yeah
if there isn't then you're getting
caught in a lot
um
I'll be right back
we have a lot of passengers who come
here with the same story they come to
shop to the United States to resell it
in their countries however most of the
times those passengers actually have a
plan and she's only coming for one day
normally when these people come they
come for three four days because if you
don't find something that one day and
you go back home what was the purpose of
your trip
so we have to make sure that she's
authentic because we have had incidents
in the past where we've had passengers
come in with the same story who have
swallowed cocaine
she says she has some money and her
credit card but you did this for work
here well that's like a debit card gift
card basically yeah
what's your name
is that her name
no what is a different name Karina it
says Karina it's not going to let her
use it
then there's something she's not telling
us or she's just lying
can't put in the pattern yeah
put your stuff away and come follow me
okay
I'm gonna put her in private room to
speak to her a little bit more see if I
can get the tooth out of her and see
where the story goes from here
take a seat right here I'm gonna search
your body
[Music]
what's her daughter's name
so the debit card is hers right yeah
yeah she's just she's too calm
she's been through this before obviously
she's been put in that room before she's
been in padded now before she said that
she made himself Jordans
and that um last time she stayed in
three months there was a few drones that
were dropping like new drawings that she
was exporting back home through here and
that's where she stayed here last minute
ticket low income you know what make
phone calls call her daughter right see
the story make sense if it makes no
sense if it's completely awesome we'd
write it up
give me your daughter's number I'm gonna
give her a call
okay wait for me
I have to charge the phone yeah
she literally only has three contacts
right now
I don't know what you want to do
come on we can have outbound check and
she's taking stuff out she doesn't take
anything out she came and she passed
or she's taking out cash
I don't have enough evidence to keep her
but every piece of information that she
gave me I couldn't verify anything
found this one
so I'm gonna make sure that we have an
inspection on our way back to Trinidad
make sure she's taking out merchandise
I'm gonna be looking after you okay
after make sure you leave tomorrow if
she's not then she's lying about
something
let me slam sniff real quick sir
all right thank you
how are you
come through sir
just quick sniff
ing after something I'm gonna take a
look at your bags real quick okay fine
are these all your bags
here
boom
it's got marijuana here
I forgot it was in my bag
we have a little bit of marijuana here
we're gonna do a test
just to verify what it is
you turn orange
faucet for marijuana
weight on the scale
it's about 12 grams it's probably worth
about 150 dollars
we will issue the fine there will be
possibly five thousand dollars
I made a mistake and had marijuana
cannabis in my bag and got to pay a 5
000 fine
because they can't arrest me because it
ain't chargeable but they can find you
for how do you feel about that
you know how I feel the same way you
would
[Music]
position three is in location
we're probably about five minutes up
since arresting the baggage handler
and the two other New York suspects both
of who worked for the airlines
previously we've developed a lot more
information on this organization we've
now identified an additional members of
this Airline internal conspiracy
we began looking at a previous video of
the JFK baggage handler
we're able to see that Not only was the
baggage handler taking cocaine from the
airport he was also moving money into
the airport to be smuggled to Southern
California
and we can see him going down from the
employee locker room at JFK to the
terminal bathroom meeting with the
individual who we later identified as
the money transporter
the money transporter is based out west
we're estimating that the baggage
handler and the money transporter in
this video were moving an estimated
anywhere from 300 to 400 000 US Dollars
the money transporter then gets on uh
aircraft and flies out to the West Coast
bypassing any TSA or security
checkpoints those proceeds were going to
be utilized to purchase more kilos of
cocaine through a Mexican connect
we were able to identify the money
transporter he lives here in Vegas and
we developed a plan with Homeland
Security investigations in Las Vegas on
how we would affect the rest of the
targets
so right over there is the target
vehicle that burgundy color sedan and on
the corner there is the target residence
we're pretty confident he's in the
residence the residence comes back to
him his vehicle that's registered to him
is parked in front of the house
we're gonna execute up it's called the
knock and talk we'll knock on the door
of the residents
hopefully the target will answer the
door there are several things to
consider doing a knock and talk from an
officer safety standpoint
you know they could always run back in
the house they could grab a weapon you
never know how many people are going to
be in the house so you kind of don't
really know what you're walking into
okay
is it yours it's my husband would he be
able to come out
contact with there to be a female
[Music]
we have a confirmation that that's our
Target we're gonna play some under
arrest
foreign
[Music]
we have confirmation that that's our
Target we're gonna Place him under
arrest
[Music]
what is this about what is it and we'll
discuss that in a little bit we're sure
you have the right person this this is a
joke right wait wait
relax breathe
the HSI Las Vegas office they did a
great job got them away from his
children and family make sure there was
no you know no safety issues or anything
like that long time get out of here as
quick as you can we'll see how it
happens back at the office
[Music]
the day before I saw this female coming
from the Caribbean she told me she's
coming to purchase clothing she owns a
store in Trinidad and told me she's
leaving today
you seen
we have an inspection outgoing I want to
make sure she leaves and I want to make
sure she takes back merchandise if she
doesn't leave then we have a problem and
she leaves with no merchandise we have
an even bigger problem maybe she came
and she passports
[Music]
love I see you
I got her
hello my name is
coming with family no
check your luggage and you'll be on your
way
[Music]
what was the purpose of a trip
um
oh okay when you came into the US yes so
yesterday just one day it's not enough
time to shop it's too little
and when you came in how much money you
brought into the U.S cash money
then how much money are you taking back
home
no cash you weren't sure you spend at
all okay pretty good
this is a new stuff for your jersey oh
okay you have any receipt of the stuff
you bought
it okay it's good
you're checking her bags we feel like
the purpose she initially told me is
legitimate so I'm gonna go ahead and
release the passenger right now
the majority of the time we spend hours
on the passenger drilling them asking
questions because we think we have
something good but we get a lot more
negatives and positives
but I'm Gonna Keep Looking we're going
to keep talking and who knows maybe
we'll actually find something thank you
for your time have a good flight
guys thanks everyone for coming today so
after the arrest of the money transport
our investigation opened up into a
larger conspiracy
this organization would send the cocaine
from Curacao to New York's JFK Airport
then send those proceeds to Southern
California
where they were purchased more cocaine
that was imported from Mexico
that cocaine was then sent from Southern
California to the New York area
we were able to introduce an undercover
agent from our Long Beach office
that undercover agent was able to pick
up one kilogram of cocaine from the
source of supply
and today we'll be flying in the JFK to
deliver that cocaine to the recipient
who paid for it the New York distributor
I'm also the former Airline employee
here in New York what we're going to try
to do today is to conduct and control
delivery
basically what's going to happen is when
the flight lands the UC will start
getting in contact right he hasn't been
in contact with the target yet but no
yeah so he basically you could say like
hey I'm on the ground where should I go
and then right from there we should have
an idea what's going on he just goes up
to the window pulls out the kilo hands
it to them they'll probably look at it
pay him his payment and then it'll be
taken down the UC will be taken down
with the other targets so just everyone
know that
tequila cocaine so with his drugs
there's guns right so be safe you know
work together the most important part is
the security of the on the cover if
anyone sees anything anyone hears
anything you don't like call it out
we'll stop it the nearest Hospital
trauma one Center Jamaica okay something
happens anybody get them in get them out
just go
it says flight still tracking for 10.55
so the game plan is we're going to have
a group of Agents be the cover team for
the undercover the rest of the agents
will be spread out on foot as well as in
vehicles in the parking garage and the
terminal we're going to be driving by in
a second so just tap your brakes
gotcha okay this is us coming right by
you all right so you guys are in a great
spot
like if he was going to meet him I think
they'd meet here that's the best bet you
know
these guys might know this a lot you
know what I mean yeah
the New York distributor was a former
Airline employee so he's very familiar
with that terminal they know there's
cameras all over the place that's why
we're worried about counter surveillance
try keeping an eye on see what's in
these calls too you know what I mean if
you see anybody like that guy sitting
there with his lights on
all right looks like the flight has
touched down
flight has touched down careful copy
that we're all positioned around the
terminal making our way to the Rival
game
[Music]
what are you bringing back with you from
over there yes
anybody give you anything to bring each
day each officer might have three to
five good passengers travel together
right
we talked to them we speak to them we
check their bags and you'll continue on
to you're satisfied
to declare
[Music]
I just do a head
that's weird
you wear these
give me a second all right
it's a bedroom
so you can see how it's darker on the
bottom it's like really like dense very
dense it's completely off the swing
Yep they're loaded oh definitely
[Music]
there you go white powder
from the odor I'm going to say it's
cocaine
this is the sole of the shoe and that
yellow packet is loaded
get it tested
oh it's so thick
there you go Blue
positive for cocaine
I'm just gonna take you to another area
and process you are
your wife know about this no it's not
time to be lying to
your wife know about this
she does so why she acting like she
don't know about it
the only thing that's load is those
shoes
they're gonna weigh both the shoes
together
[Music]
it smells so strong oh my God it's like
a weird mustard smell yes that's what we
do all the time it's a cat in the mouse
game you know
one finds that everybody helps it's a
team effort just your thumb like that so
much hard work we got a lot of negatives
but when we hit it's a good feeling
foreign
[Music]
we'll make sure no one is on his tail
copy thank you
all right
[Music]
you have to Industry or child
representation
[Music]
we just got word that our targets
contacted our undercover and they are
going to be meeting up at the departure
level which is right here
showing sending out updates on location
they're walking through the terminal
slow okay
[Music]
our Undercovers on the escalator right
now
and we have agents at the arrival and
departure areas so we're a few minutes
out
[Music]
uc's outside by door number seven
it's him right there right
the backpack yeah yeah that's him
all units supposedly the targets are in
a black Ford Explorer that's all tinted
out targets are saying they're at seven
and then just watch his level don't be
surprised that this happens quick
[Music]
now black SUV just rolled up it's a
black Ford Explorer with tinted windows
entering the departure area right now
that may be it
see it look at that black explorer right
there the one in the Middle with the
tail light out yeah
it's got to be our guy right there man
gets that car right behind you guys
therefore I'm blocking whenever you're
ready
[Music]
It's that car right behind you guys
therefore I'm blocking whenever you're
ready
our targets are looking for our
undercover right now
okay that's all you see going right to
the vehicle
and everybody stand by Vinnie wait for
all signal you'll see the lights and
close it off when we take it down all
right
when he walks away yeah make sure you
help close this road get ahead of it get
ahead of them yeah okay but let them
clear
[Music]
all right we're gonna be taking it down
all units take it down
get out
go go
right now
I gotcha
oh my goodness
step out hands up come up
all right
got anything on you no come on is there
anything on you there's nothing on me
you got any weapons anything I need to
know about more
just relax man give us five seconds all
right just relax I don't know anything
all right that's fine that's fine relax
relax
thank you
we'll get them back take them to the
side all right okay let's go get him in
a car let's go
all right so we got our two Targets we
got our two guys we got a bag they still
got the drugs nobody got hurt everything
is good
this investigation began with us
identifying a baggage handler in New
York it led us to a huge International
conspiracy with the movement of well
over thousands of kilos of cocaine
unload it we'll lay out everything these
organizations with that amount of
Narcotics you're looking at
multi-million if not billions of dollars
that are being made we're definitely
going to be sending all this stuff for
prints and DNA swabs thus far in the
investigation we're able to seize 10
kilograms of cocaine 550
000 US dollars made multiple arrests and
all the evidence we gathered will help
us prosecute these individuals
thank you
this is a joke right hey relax
relax
[Music]
[Applause]
you got another flight you're doing
after this this is just the beginning
we turn over every Rock we look at every
phone we look at every suspect
it takes a lot of time and dedication
but we're gonna do whatever we can to
disrupt and dismantle this criminal
organization
[Music]